buying something to impress other people
always feels empty because they're not
the ones with it 99% of the time I
quickly feel like a fraud in that kind
of situation and I also feel very weak
when I do something for other people
because it makes me feel vulnerable
which I don't like cuz then it makes me
feel like my subjective well-being is
based on their interpretation or their
projection of who they think I am and I
don't like that eliminating those things
almost to be fair to a degree going in
complete contrast to that and hoping
people underestimate me to some degree
I'm asking for it because I look the way
I look right there's not a lot of
wealthy private equity guys who walk
around in a beater and a faded trucker
hat